we're in South Africa to look into a
video for a clothing company two and a
half million people have seen one of the
world's greatest predators play with a
man named Kevin Richardson when I first
watched this it looked real but I just
couldn't imagine it it seemed so bizarre
and crazy that he would just be playing
with the Lions like their little kittens
well we've heard of Dances with Wolves
but never sucker with lions because
you're not quite sure if this is a fake
but apparently it's not so he's really
playing and interacting with lions Lions
are dangerous and the film crew used
cages for their safety so how is keV
able to avoid being mauled these Lions
are actually living in a Wildlife
Sanctuary in South Africa and they have
known Kevin since they were about six
months old unlike some other animals
that operate in groups lion prides don't
actually have a hierarchy so there's no
dominant member to look up to they don't
see Kevin as the dominant lion they see
him as just another member of the pride
if Mayans haven't seen one member of
their pride for a while they'll actually
engage in certain behaviors to reinforce
the bond of the pride like saying
welcome back and those are things like
rubbing their heads against each other
and leaning into each other and knocking
each other over interestingly male lions
will only ever initiate this kind of a
social exchange with another male so
what we're seeing in the clip is Kevin
literally being just one of the guys yes
keV may be The Lion King but Hakim isn't
impressed so what he's a member of a
pride of lions I'm a member of a colony
of ants we play frisbee all the time